I definitely did not apply for you agree
huh me first
quick question of the rhetorical variety
that's you right um no what do you what
do you know
look at you go Wow nice catch 3000
pounds 40 miles an hour
it's not easy got mad skills that's all
that's all on YouTube though right I
mean that's where you found that because
you know that's not fake it's all done
on a computer
mm-hm it's like that video yeah yeah
yeah oh you mean like those UFOs over
Phoenix so your this spider wing
crime-fighting spider your spider boy
my spider-man not in that onesie or not
it's not a onesie believe this I was
actually having a really good day today
you know I start didn't miss my train
this perfectly good DVD player was just
sitting there and algebra test nailed it
who else knows anybody nobody not even
your unusually attractive him no no no
no no if she knew she would freak out
and when she freaks out I freaked out
you know what I think it's really cool
this webbing tensile strength is off the
charts
what manufactured that I did climbing
walls are you doing that adhesive gloves
it's a long story
I was already can you even see in these
yes yes I can't I can't I can't see in
those okay it's just that when whatever
happened happened it's like my senses
have been dialed 211 there's there's way
too much input so they they just kind of
help me focus you're in dire need of an
upgrade systemic top to bottom hundred
point restoration that's why I'm here
why are you doing this
I gotta know what's your mo what gets
you out of that twin bed in the morning
because
because I've been me my whole life and
I've had these powers for six months
mm-hmm
I read books I build computers and and
yeah I would love to play football but I
couldn't then so I shouldn't natural cuz
you're different exactly but I can't
tell anybody that so I'm not look when
you can do the things that I can but you
don't
and then the bad things happen they
happen because you
so you want to look out for the little
guy you want to do your part make the
world a better place on that right yeah
yeah yeah just looking after
I'm gonna sit here so you move the leg
good passport no I don't I don't even
have a drive ever been to Germany no oh
you'll love it I can't go to Germany why
I got homework I'm gonna pretend you
didn't say that I'm being serious I
can't just drop out of slightly a little
dangerous better tell aunt hottie I'm
taking about this don't tell it me
all right spiral
[Music]
communes sorry I'll get